good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday we are
so close to friday it's feeling so close
so close i can see it but it's not right
there
it's one day away and that is okay
hope everyone's having a fabulous
morning so far we are so excited to be
coming at you live and living color from
manhattan
what used to be formerly the greatest
city on earth formerly the greatest city
on earth we need to talk about this
um we haven't spoken about it yet uh
really i feel like we talk about it all
the time no no no no no we have we
always talk about like manhattan's
[ __ ] blah blah blah but what's
happened in the city in the last
few months month or so you could feel it
in the air the quality of life
is really deteriorating deteriorated um
yet it's still the most expensive city
in the world so it's like what are we
doing here i don't know what we're doing
here most people
like have fled numbers of people who
have left the city
are staggering um the city is just in
disarray
i actually was going to share that
yesterday i had probably one of the
worst days i've had in quarantine and
then i cvs
punching machine day no it was a
cleveland day it was a day
where i got on zillow otherwise like
cleveland ohio
i think we need to change a cleveland
day it's a charlotte day because if we
do every move we are moving to charlotte
yeah no but like you know what kind of
day that is like a day where it's just
like i will
pack all my things in a handbag yeah and
flee this town leave the rest behind
and never come back and never look back
you know i've been having
well actually i don't leave my house so
i haven't been having many of those days
but when i do make the very brave
decision to leave my house
it's just you could you could feel it in
the air there's just something
different about the city and it's it's
not what it used to be and i don't know
how long it'll take to recover and i
can't even put my finger on what's wrong
with the city but
there's like a palpable difference in
just quality of life
yeah and it's not even about quarantine
anymore no
i hated to say like it was a bad day in
quarantine because we're in phase three
like
we're now just in purgatory right um
where it's like we can go places but
we're just
still staying home yeah and we're we're
not staying home because of corona
anymore like we're staying home because
the city is just not where you want to
be i'm actually still staying home
because of corona i
you know i made it this far i really
don't want to catch it the um the rate
of infection now in new york is like
below one percent well yes when i got my
covid test at city md
i said how long is it going to take and
when you and margot went they said what
two to three days
yeah and it was quicker than that it's
now seven to ten days and i said excuse
me what
and she's like yeah no the labs are so
overbooked with other
states that have now become hot spots
new york is no longer a priority because
it's not really a hot spot anymore
yeah which is good obviously but i'm
still waiting for my results i thought
maybe she was like seven to ten and then
it would like come tomorrow
so i've been checking every day but they
haven't come yet and you just got tested
just
i got tested for antibodies and then i'm
like while i'm there might as well just
like maybe
see if i have corona i feel fine i'm
just maybe i'm one of those people you
know it's just like
asymptomatic asymptomatic i get like a
little tinkle in my throat
yeah actually one year ago today um i
was looking at my time up i had strep
throat
which reminded me like not to jinx but i
haven't had strep throat in so long and
i used to be on like a two to three a
year times basis
um and obviously i saw because my time
up was just pictures of my tonsils and
all the blisters on my tonsils
and it just reminded me like we should
be so grateful for our health you guys
it's it's the only thing that matters
it's very true do you know that i've
never had strep throat
even as a child even as a child i've
never
and i had like a throat ache and i was
convinced it was strep throat and i went
to the doctor and it wasn't
like i've never had strep i like don't
believe you not that you're lying like
you probably forgot
no no no i just every and i it was
honestly a little disappointing because
it's like i'm in so much pain
right how do i not have stress give me
the amoxicillin yeah and it wasn't
strep any of those times i find that so
hard to believe it's such a common thing
for kids
i know and for me it's literally a
common thing like every year
as an adult i don't think there's any
like common
illness like i'm not comparing it to
like illnesses that happen in hospital
but like strep throat
the flu like i don't i actually think
strep throat is worse than the flu if
you get it bad
holy [ __ ] i've had it many times and
there are two occasions that come to
mind where i actually thought i was
gonna die
i actually wouldn't know what it feels
like if i've never had it you should be
so blessed
it's the worst and like when you have it
you're like oh my god i wish i just had
like the flu i wish i just had food
poisoning because
there's nothing worse than this [ __ ]
strep throat it's awful i cannot believe
that you've never had it
i remember like as kids it was like the
one thing when you went to the doctor
and you weren't feeling well they just
like always tested you for straps yeah
and they shoved that thing down your
throat because that's usually what it
was
um and like you would giggle because the
real strap is streptococcus
and you're like cocky i didn't even know
that i wasn't even in on this you're not
part of the club i'm not part of the
sharp throat club wow how sad the stc
that's amazing yeah wow you learned
something new about your sister every
day
i should add that to my like two truths
in a lie repertoire
yes that's a really good one you know i
always struggle with those
sorts of icebreakers me too um every
time i've ever played that game i
always say three lies like i just i
can't even come up with the truth about
myself
let alone a lie the lies are easier to
come up with the lies
the lie no i'm like i was born in canada
my eye color is fake and i'm allergic to
dairy
all lies all live so i just let the
audience choose i'm like you're right
how did you know
that is so funny well yeah so anyways it
was it was a big time cleveland day
um a big time anywhere but here day is
yeah i know
and if you're a toaster and you're in
the city
godspeed godspeed got to be with you um
so i was all alone yesterday by myself
because
then went to play golf you only hear the
most crazy thing
sure ben left the house to play golf at
8 am
what time do you think you got home 10
p.m eleven
what was he doing playing golf and he
played in west hampton which is so far
two hours each way then they stopped for
lunch she stopped for dinner
and like i actually got home he got home
and i refused to speak to him i'm like
it like there's and you know what i
don't even mind not
being with him like i like being alone i
obviously prefer especially at night
also because i had a traumatic
experience in my apartment over the
weekend
my dog walker came and i opened the door
and he said
he said the most upsetting thing you can
hear a human being say
and he said i have to let you know i
just got off the elevator and i saw two
cockroaches
go under the door of of one of the
apartments on your floor
and you have no idea how upsetting that
is because i take extermination
very seriously like if i see any sort
and by the way for those who don't live
in new york
it's i know like we make it sound so
glamorous but it's
it's actually not rodents whether it be
roaches or mice are a
very very common occurrence like in the
fanciest best
no one is above it like literally no one
it's partially due
to the fact that the city is very not
clean partially due to the subways
it's just it's very common also since
the quarantine
actually um the rodents and the
cockroaches they've gotten
like it's been sort of like right on rat
crime out there
because a gang war yeah no there's been
gang wars among the rats and i have to
assume among the cockroaches because the
restaurants have been closed so they
don't have food access to the food that
they normally have
so they've been eating each other
leading to like a super rat phenomenon
oh my god survival of the fitness
they're getting bigger so the only rats
that are here are the biggest and the
baddest but see this makes me think like
this is a new york problem but you know
other regions of the country have their
own roading problems like i think in
certain parts of the country it's like
you can get snakes in certain part of
the country
you can get like lizards like i think in
arizona like the drier areas
so it's like i don't i honestly like i
don't know what's worse i think i could
handle a lizard over a roach
roaches and so i have seen so in my
you know 25 years you know 15 of which
have been spent in new york
um i have had my fair share of rodent
experiences and it it paralyzes you like
it
it takes over your life and you your
home is not your home anymore it is
literally like
a nightmare it's a living nightmare i
like i'll never forget
when i saw a roach in our house growing
up once it changed my life forever i was
no longer comfortable in my own home i
would enter every room
open the door stand outside scan the
floor and then walk in
so when my dog walker came and said i
can't even like have this conversation
because i have the will
he came and he said i saw two roaches it
and so they were a duo it was a duo and
it just killed me because i take
extermination so seriously you know
our automatics take sketch comedy very
seriously i take extermination very
excited
i've never seen a duo like together
joined at the hip
in the city no it was literally a tag
team bonnie and clyde
velma and louise and jackie and claudia
my building has a
exactly my building has a monthly
exterminator that comes to every
apartment and does the whole building
and then i also have a monthly like i
have not one but two and i've lived in
the apartment for
almost two years and i haven't seen
anything so it was about time that i
worked to see something
um but it just it ruined me like it just
it shattered
my emotional well-being like i can't
sleep now i had to dream about the
cockroach like
it's it's just
it's it's devastating for for my entire
building and the community i'm so sorry
to hear that
i feel as though on the plus side though
having a dog might help
feels technically a dog no but like if
he were to see
but theo essentially went to private
school you know he's not really
hunter but you know what i he'll rise to
the challenge he'll step up to the plate
what's one thing you've asked of him
that he
that he didn't do for you oh my god i
have to tell you something heartbreaking
stop it's really bad it's not
like this is so many elements of the
story are gonna completely like
devastate you
stop i already knew the first half so
just bring it no you don't what's the
first half that you saw two roaches oh
oh no this is a totally it's about the o
oh my god okay ceo for the first time in
probably two years oh my god a button
fell off my shirt yes you know i saw
that button
and i was walking down the street and
like my breast was exposed
because it was right there my button had
fallen off and i was like how am i gonna
find this button
it's right literally right there go get
it um okay back to the story that's
gonna
break your heart for the first time in
about two years
okay oh theo had an accident okay
there's more to it
but wait there's more but wait there's
more give me my solo camera
theo had an accident on the love sack
what yeah what kind of accident
one one yeah another one okay um but
unfortunately i do think it is a part of
an overall problem that i'm
working out with the vet i think theo
may be suffering from a uti
which is very decorative which is very
which is very uncommon
in male dogs but my vet has told me
forever that theo has a very feminine
spirit
um because he's followed by i mean he
hangs out with a lot of feminine energy
and he pees like a girl like all this
stuff
so it's not impossible but it's very
uncommon for a male dog to have
a uti but i think my boy might be
special and he might have a uti we're
gonna
we're gonna take him to get an x-ray
okay well you know what like uti's once
identified and
prescribed they're they're they're okay
manageable but i'm just i'm so sad that
he had to imagine
imagine having a uti and not being able
to tell someone no devastating
of course you're gonna piss on the couch
and say um and on your health spot
so that you're saying mom like i'm it's
not a regular accident your son is not
okay
no it was very intentional he was trying
to communicate with me and
i i miss like i i wasn't listening
clearly and he had to make me listen
and i understood theo and i hear you you
know what i'm actually
i'm not this story does not concern me
because it shows me that theo like
he understood that he needed to get your
attention and he did what he needed to
do
that's exactly why he peed on love sex
not for right i hope he's not in pain
well he probably was in pain which is
why he had to make a scene
we're handling it stat okay well oh my
god theodore so i'm assuming that's why
he's not at work today
no i just wasn't in the mood to like get
sweaty walking him over here
yeah even though it is a bit chillier
today in the city and it's the lovely
weather
yes um this is bringing me back to the
olden times where we
have so much to talk about i well
actually i didn't like
after the show um i got my eyebrows
waxed so i was like out for
an extra hour and i had some things to
talk about
you know i was actually thinking and i
would love to maybe get some suggestions
from the audience because like people
have really come to
love deer toasters and honestly i have
two and it's like sad that it only
happens once a week and i would like to
have like one more weekly installation
like
something we do every week okay but not
to your toasters no like a different fun
segment okay so if anyone i don't have
any ideas obviously but if anyone does
i would love to hear like maybe i don't
know maybe we'll do like a team
brainstorm
yeah yeah of ideas cool um
so without further ado i do think that
it is time yeah i guess so
for the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
patreon.com morning toast
we just did an episode yesterday all
about conspiracy theories
you guys some like people are so crazy
about conspiracy theories and it really
like fueled me
um hearing how much you guys love the
episode we talked about a few
um popular ancillary ones at the end but
the big three that we talked about were
the wayfarer conspiracy which the more i
read same
the more i'm like this is so clear as
day i'm convinced
that it's true then we talked about free
britney which we concluded it's not
necessarily a conspiracy theory
just like concerned fans who are taking
it amongst themselves to bring justice
to their girl
and it's a movement for justice we
talked about the theory that some uh
of the biggest celebs are not in
quarantine actually under house arrest
right now
that one i wasn't so sure about but if
you are not
like in up to speed with the current
conspiracy theories which i wasn't it's
a great episode for you we start from
the beginning like yeah teach you
everything you need to know
uncover a lot of facts um it was really
a good episode i'm not like one for
conspiracy theories but every time i
hear one i'm like oh
it's true and i've never been more sure
of anything in my life that wayfarer
is 100 involved in some sort of
international child trafficking
um charade allegedly which is
just so awful and disgraceful um and i
think more people should be talking
about it but you know for our own safety
we have to put that episode behind a
paywall
because you never know you know we're
not trying to get axed so patreon.com
slash a morning toast it's a fabulous
way for you
guys to get more content it's 7.99 a
month for five extra episodes and the
episodes are always a little bit more in
depth we let you in a little bit more
they're either themed like conspiracy
theories or they're just more personal
about us
or vlogs with the family right so it's
always really fun
and that's where we can be our true
selves and it's just a great way to
support
the show yes if you are into supporting
our show please
support fellow podcasters patreon.com
morning toast
okay first story a follow-up to
yesterday's story
nick cannon apologizes for anti-semitic
remarks as fox announces he'll remain
host of the masked singer so nick cannon
put out a statement yesterday
after we um shared that he he didn't
apologize he didn't apologize he sort of
doubled down and said you know this is
what i said um but now he's apologizing
for the remarks that he made during a
recent podcast episode
he said quote first and foremost i
extend my deepest and most sincere
apologies to my jewish sisters and
brothers
for the hurtful and divisive words that
came out of my mouth during my interview
with richard griffin
as a jewish sister thank you thank you
for seeing me
quote they reinforce the worst
stereotypes of a proud and magnificent
people and i feel ashamed of the
uninformed and naive place
that these words came from he wrote
while the jewish experience encompasses
more than five thousand years
and there is so much i have yet to learn
i have had at least a minor history
lesson over the past few days
and to say that it is eye-opening would
be a vast understatement
he expressed his gratitude to rabbis
community leaders and institutions who
reached out
to me to help enlighten me instead of
chastising me
i want to assure my jewish friends new
and old that this is only the beginning
of my education
i'm committed to deeper connections more
profound learning and strengthening the
bond between our two cultures
today and every day going forward okay
so you know i live for an apology
because it's just a part of the
zeitgeist now and there are different
varying levels of of apology and to me
this is
this is pretty solid i'm not gonna lie
like i feel there was a partner there
that you didn't read that i would um
i'd just like to mention because to me
it was the most important part of the
apology if you would just
give me one moment i know he put it on
his instagram story it's important
enough to take your time
okay the part that i
um oh wait hold on
what was it about basically
um like acknowledging that like these
weird conspiracy theories that he was
talking about were propaganda
like i think they used and i'm pretty
sure he used the word propaganda which i
really appreciated
hold on yeah um
maybe he didn't yeah i just looked at
the tweets and i didn't see
oh i thought i did see it whatever um
on a on a scale of apologies like i i
actually genuinely like really
appreciate this apology i think it was
like really necessary and really um well
done um
now part of me like this news comes out
with conjunction that he'll remain host
of the
masked singer which obviously like the
cynic in me i'm like did he
have someone craft this apology just so
that he could keep his job on matt
singer because you know
girl's got to eat but um i'll choose to
be
optimistic and not think that that's how
the world works i really appreciated the
apology i thought it was very very well
done
and um yeah i mean i don't know what
else we could ask for at this point so
yeah i it didn't even cross my mind that
it could be connected to keeping his job
and that someone else might have written
it
um i thought it was a very
genuine as genuine as you could be the
apology and i
when people apologize like i take it at
face value and i
try to forgive so if these are his words
and
and this is how he feels i'm in the
business of forgiveness
100 and i'm in the business of lifting
each other up yeah
and i liked what he said about learning
and moving forward and trying
to and recognizing how he was wrong and
that he was wrong and and that's really
all you can ask of people
and we'll see what happens going forward
that's that's
that's how you can judge people not what
they say but what they do
moving forward but for now like i'm i'm
okay
you know and you know what i i yesterday
when he wasn't apologizing and i was
like wow not only are there people who
think this but even when called out
and the thing about this conspiracy
theory it's kind of where
anti-semitic things it's it's kind of a
genius thing it's like
we're telling you that jews control the
world and so if i get fired for this it
just proves
what i'm saying right but no you're not
getting fired because jews control the
world you're getting fired because you
said something incredibly offensive to a
magnificent group of people right
so when he wasn't apologizing it made me
feel really sad i was like wow there's
people who really think this way and
they're gonna put their stake in the
ground and and
and not relent and die on this hill so
i'm really grateful
that he apologized in what seems to be a
very sincere way
and we'll see what happens from here
we'll see what happens from here but for
now like
it's noted and it's appreciated yes
definitely and i like nick cannon so
hopefully it can stay that way yeah it's
it's sad when it's someone you like
yeah no if it's someone you hate it's
like oh i knew all along you know but
when it's someone you like
it it's painful yeah and you also want
to give them the benefit of the doubt
of course and i am so about have they
done the
give people the benefit of the doubt
it's so valuable it says so in the bible
yes claudia that's beautiful maybe that
should be the name
should we have today's name of the
episode be in hebrew
okay that would be cool have i done the
hofstra yeah that one
okay i don't know like i don't know if
that's like the exact verbiage i'll have
to look it up
okay uh this next story is really crazy
um as we mentioned last week amber heard
johnny depp are in court
oh my god honestly i can't with the
messiest couple of 20 20. like
these people are out of control i don't
know who's side to take i don't really
even [ __ ] care
i'm so over these people but what
happened now amber hurt has been accused
of stealing her ex-assistance sexual
violence
what amber heard stole her former
assistant a former assistant's harrowing
story of surviving a rape at knifepoint
then twisted it to use against warring
husband johnny depp
the ex-staffer alleged in a uk court on
wednesday
kate james told depp's libel case in
london's high court that her
former boss had summoned turned 2013 so
that she could pump her for information
on surviving a six-hour rape while
traveling in brazil
what quote miss heard referred to a
conversation we had about me being
violently raped at machete point in
brazil and she used it as her own story
james told the court on where did she
use it as her own story
um she referred to it she referred
directly to a violent rape that occurred
to
her 26 years ago and she twisted it into
her own story and used it for her own
use um wait oh my god by the way this
story about this assistant can we talk
about that for a minute that's horrible
horrible machete six hour rape oh my god
that's absolutely awful and the fact
that now she has to rehash it
in such a public oh my god that's
[ __ ] terrible
yeah this couple is just
like i'm starting to hate them both
individually like for
making me listen to that this trash and
i somehow ended up on a part of the
internet last night where i saw a
picture
of the judy amber heard shut up the judy
amber heard took it
around the world yep and it was it was a
duty that's what i'll say it was
duty-licious
and it it's i'm i'm officially after
this story i'm trying to end this couple
unless it's like the most groundbreaking
earth shattering
i i'm not interested in them going
tit-for-tat about what happened in their
marriage like they both
i just i it's so messy and this is
taking it to a whole other
deplorable level yeah i completely agree
this poor assistant who's just trying to
like make a living
and now she's out you know sitting in
court
in front of the press talking about like
one of the most
horrible moments of her life like the
story just keeps getting worse and worse
and with your permission i'd like to
formally
johnny depp amber heard you have been
china you are no longer only spoken
about on the show unless extenuating
circumstances like something crazy
happens but
after seeing the picture of the duty and
like not to be so graphic
where did it eat you oh how did you why
i'm so glad you asked at duty lane do i
wound up on duty.com
courtesy of bar stool sports like they
obviously ran a picture of it and i
clicked on it because i followed them on
twitter and i was just like
what does it mean what does a human duty
look like out of a toilet bowl i don't
know i've never made one out of but they
look different
yeah because the
[Laughter]
and the water can also like erode i
think the water
i just based on what i saw oh man i'm
like actually getting gagged because now
i'm just like remembering the picture i
don't forget about it when it hits the
bowl it could break
no but because the water keeps it solid
it keeps it afloat
the water is very helpful in keeping it
solid whereas when i saw it on the bed
sheet maybe it has been sitting there
for a long time
it had started to melt
sorry it's true don't look it up i'll
just paint a picture okay the sheets
were white the duty was brown
oh my god i'm not okay and honestly just
it made me want to sing
in the toilet out the sewer into all
that gross manure
see the toilet spinning round then i put
the lid
back down my duty brown my duty browned
i don't remember the rest of the lyrics
you know what since it's like
a dutylicious week um next episode of
the redheads i will have dana saying my
duty brown oh my god i like did not know
where you were going with that sentence
since this has been a delicious episode
i think we're gonna say i took a massive
dump yesterday
and then you're like the episode of the
red well because
that's dana's song it's a dana original
song dana who is a co-host on the
redheads one of jackie's friends from
college her and her cousin made up this
weird song when they were kids
yeah it's honestly fabulous she's sung
it on the show before
um but now that she is part of her own
podcast i think it's time that she
graced us
yeah i think maybe you should also have
her film it for sure
okay we'll do so yes back to the story
unfortunately i will no longer be able
to give a comment
due to legal restrictions on the china
ang of amber heard and johnny depp
they're both just honestly disgraceful
okay
great next story some happy news
pregnant gigi hadid reveals the first
glimpse of her baby bump
yeah gigi hadid had fans in a state of
excitement when she showed off her
growing baby belly on an instagram live
this wednesday
the model unbuttoned her flowing pajama
top and turned to the side so that fans
could see
she's not uh hiding her stomach as some
had previously suggested
like it's so [ __ ] annoying it's just
from the front
it looks different she said um she went
on to acknowledge that some people are
confused by her decision not to post or
discuss her pregnancy
but she said that's because she believes
it's not the most important thing going
on in the world
oh also it's like what are you confused
about a mother wanting to protect her
unborn child from like the hatred of
social media
i don't see anything wrong with that i'm
i'm confused by a lot of things i'm not
confused by a pregnant woman not wanting
to share her journey on social media
people are just
so evil like yeah that's literally it
makes so much sense to me
no it makes a ton of sense to me um but
i guess if people were confused
hopefully they're no longer confused um
also someone pointed something out on in
like one of our instagram comments
sections yesterday that
kind of blew my mind and i never really
put the two together it's just
interesting how sophie turner and gigi
hadid are pregnant at the same time
when they are so inextricably linked via
joe jonas
is that just like interesting timing
inextricably yeah no i hadn't put that
together that is crazy
and i remember when remember when they
were at the most recent
vmas or the mtv awards and sophie and
joe were there together
and gigi was like rumored to be dating
tyler c but she yes
but she went with bella and like they
were sitting all in the celebrity
section and i guess that not that many
celebrities could make it
um so they were very close to each other
and it's like joe is with yes i remember
that's where taylor swift
performed right yes yes yes joe was with
the queen of the north yeah
gigi is like dating a bachelor
contestant
stop thank you um
yes i mean we talk about this all the
time and so but now
it's like he's with the queen of the
north but she's with
one direction but for ggid like she was
always gonna make it out of that
relationship fine
for the joe jonas element it was like he
was this could have gone either way they
were dating during the dnce year so it
wasn't like he was this like
major major mega star that he is now he
was super famous
but i think a lot of people were like
damn he got gg hadid like that's good
for him
and when she bounced and went back to
zayn like it was
you know it was devastating and we're
like damn joe jonas back put in his
place
but he ended up we always say like it's
crazy because when you date ggid like
you can't ever
date someone on the same level but jojo
has managed to find literally like
someone so [ __ ] perfect and fabulous
that like
it's just as good it's better it's yeah
not to compare no not to compare but
like the love they have they're having a
kid like that's perfect
yeah no it's it's really beautiful um i
love seeing the photos of them and
stepping out
she's bumping a lot of celebrities are
bumping right now yes it's
honestly like not that they could have
planned it but this is a good time to be
like
your third trimester because you can't
really leave the house and you know you
don't have fomo
if it's like the world's going on around
you it's not a terrible time to be
pregnant
no i don't think so it's not an ideal
time or it wasn't maybe like a few
months ago when the hospitals were so
overcrowded it was not an ideal time to
be giving birth because you know there's
a pandemic you don't necessarily like
want to be at a hospital epicenter and
then there was like a limited
amount of beds like it was kind of crazy
for a minute but
it's not a bad time to be pregnant i
agree
um okay next story really crazy um
if just the headline will load here it
is okay haley bieber apologizes to a
restaurant hostess who claimed that she
was not nice
haley bieber took to tick tock to
apologize to a restaurant hostess who
claimed the model was not nice
so um days ago uh julia caroline took to
tick tock to rate celebrities
who she previously met while working as
a hostess in a fancy manhattan
restaurant by the way i love these tick
tocks it's like a trend now and it's my
favorite thing
in her video julia gave hadid hadid a
rating of 10 out of 10 and said they
were so nice and were super polite and
friendly with staff
which as julia noted is rare for
celebrities after raiding cameron dallas
a 4 out of 10 for her encounter with the
social media star
julia then shared her experience with
haley quote this is going to be
controversial
i've met her a handful of times and
every time she was not nice
i really want to like her but i have to
give her like a 3.5 out of 10.
damn in response haley took to ticah to
offer a sincere apology
uh she wrote in the comments just came
across this video and wanted to say
so sorry if i've ever given you bad
vibes or a bad attitude that's not ever
my intention
you know this is a this is kind of big
of haley bieber because
you know these types of videos come out
all the time like it comes and goes it
does it wouldn't have become like a
major news story like
honestly haley commenting on it makes it
mainstream right
this would i would not have seen it i
wouldn't have seen a tick tock she also
said
hate hearing that that was your
experience with me but glad you called
me out so i can do better hopefully we
meet again so i can apologize in person
wow i mean that that's really and that
makes me think like she's not an
[ __ ] like in real life because she
she didn't need to comment on it even
though like her and justin are always
commenting on like
little level instagram posts like
theories etc
uh i think they're bored i think it
takes a big person to admit that you
were a [ __ ] and that you're going to try
and do better and that you're sorry
when it would have been much easier for
her to ignore it and less people would
have even heard about this story and i
think that's like what a real diva would
have done
right no i actually i really am like i
respect this hardcore
um i just feel like the way
whether it's like a celebrity or just
like friends like i always find like if
you're at a restaurant
and you are with someone who it's like
it's like embarrassing for like you to
be associated with them like the way
they speak to the staff like
that is just that is the lowest in my
opinion like the lowest level of
humanity
yeah in this book i just read um there's
like a good quote that i highlighted
where it's like
you can tell pretty much everything you
need to know about a person from the way
they treat
um wait staff so kind of like
went into it a little bit more um just
how that's like
a true tell no of humanity i couldn't
agree more like
i actually remember i had this friend in
college like i literally
saw her do like the most disrespectful
thing and like i actually didn't talk to
her after that like it was just
like we were at the desk at our dorm
getting packages
and you had to sign for your package so
she took the pen
and she didn't say thank you or anything
to like the person working behind the
desk and she took the pen and she signed
and then like
literally threw the pen back in the
person's face like it was just such a
it was so [ __ ] rude and it honestly
shook me to my course so hard
um that i really never spoke to her
again after that it's it's a true
telling of like a person's insides
wow yeah it really is so
but i commend here obviously i don't
commend her for being a [ __ ] at first
but i commend her for like owning up to
it when like she could have let it slide
100
therefore making it a bigger story with
her acknowledging it yes
fifth and final story a little tech news
ooh let me get my airpods in
major twitter accounts were hacked in a
cryptocurrency scam yesterday like the
accounts of joe biden elon musk bill
gates kanye west barack obama and more
send out tweets that seem to be
associated with cryptocurrency scam on
wednesday
um so i'm not sure if you saw this well
so wait i saw it on elon musk's twitter
and i'm like you know what
i didn't even think it was weird i'm
like not from him yeah no so i'm like oh
cool
he's into bitcoin now so i guess some
hackers hacked these major celebrities
public figures
twitter accounts and like were able to
get
like a hundred thousand dollars in
cryptocurrency oh they stole from people
i i guess so it's really confusing but
then also like twitter like was having a
hard time getting a handle on it and so
they
deactivated or made it so that like all
verified accounts
couldn't tweet yeah they didn't
deactivate but they blocked all verified
accounts from tweeting which you know we
are verified so we were directly
impacted by this oh i didn't even check
i didn't even try to tweet but i just
figured that i was directly impacted by
they said we are aware of a security
incident impacting accounts on twitter
we are investigating and taking steps to
fix it we will update everyone
shortly many verified accounts were
blocked from tweeting for a portion of
the day
as twitter looked into the incident
about three hours later their support
account said that most accounts
should be able to tweet again quote as
we continue working on a fix this
functionality may come and go
um and it was just a tough day for them
at twitter said jack dorsey i mean that
makes me so sad for the people who like
thought that they were gonna get two
thousand dollars in bitcoin if they sent
elon musk a thousand that was the thing
it's like
send me a thousand bitcoin and i'll send
you 2000 back oh my god that makes me so
sad
that means that i mean it's a hundred
thousand that means only
a hundred people got played which isn't
terrible but it's still like those
people lost a thousand dollars that's so
sad when they were just trying to like
make some bitcoin money hopefully
they'll be able to send it back
send it back or figure it out find the
hackers
and also i'd seen an article that the
hack they were able to hack it through
like the employee
side of twitter huh so interessant
might want to tighten that up truly well
you know another day another security
breach that's life here in america
now next up we've got one of my favorite
segments about our girl kelly ripa it's
a little
kelly's mindless news like the 4th of
july
i also don't think that we should record
that sound because singing it brings a
pe
so much joy yeah no it's good for my
mental health to keep singing it it's
like um
when we sing i don't want to start
singing because i won't be able to stop
but s
snitch on this or also angel
oh my god don't even start we have so
many annoying songs i'm surprised people
still listen to the show but when i
listen to s on the t um because we have
a button for it i
it's the phone you break it out she's a
little bit john you can find me in the
club
snitch on the toes well today's episode
of kelly's mind
i mean today's segment of kelly's
mindless news is brought to you by
honestly
entertainment tonight which is a little
disappointing
kelly ripa jokes she's on and on what
level of mindlessness is it so
let's say so there's varying degrees of
mindlessness but then there's
types of articles that open us up to a
possible conspiracy theory about kelly
right but this is not this is just
news okay because i just want to say
like i think we should create a scale
um what you shared the other day about
the the home
decor was a 10 out of 10 off the charts
mindless conspiracy story when we get
kelly ripa is wearing a swimsuit
cover-up i'm going to give that a
a three to four of mine this is a three
to four okay kelly ripa jokes
she's on an all carbohydrate diet in
quarantine
that's so original kelly kelly ripa's
diet has changed amid quarantine
the 49 year old morning show host
appeared on jimmy kimmel live wednesday
alongside ryan seacrest
and told guest host sebastian maniscalco
how being cooped up inside has affected
what she eats
i eat solid food i am not on an
all-liquid diet
i'm on an all-carbohydrate diet ripa
joked
that's what changed during the pandemic
you know what i actually um what's
annoying here is that this is news but i
really actually can relate to that i
have been on a
full carbohydrate diet since the
beginning of quarantine because
it's like what's easiest to cook and
what's most accessible
um so i weirdly can relate to kelly on
this one it's just like no one was
writing up the fact that i
think i legit said this three months and
i also feel like we're as a society
we're like
evolved a little past like writing up
female celebrities diets you know what i
mean
i would hope so yeah it's just like you
remember when we used to be like
obsessed with those tabloid magazines
like at the airport
and then like the last page would be
like khloe kardashian would i eat in a
day and it's just like
i think they still do that i think they
do too i just feel like societally like
we
may have evolved past the need for those
i don't know but i feel like now there's
youtube videos what i eat in a day right
and it is kind of interesting and i
think for people who eat healthy or who
cook
interesting things what do you want to
say what are you trying to say no but
like
it's it could be inspiring i don't think
it's all bad but
i think on a woman's diet
it's strange i think jamila jamil that
might be her next target
the what i eat in the days yeah but
sometimes it's interesting
you know i do like to see what people
usually do yeah um all right that was
kelly's mindless news and now we're
gonna dive into the tv
recap segment because we're gonna talk
about real housewives of beverly hills
which was the most glamorous
fabulous amazing episode
it was stellar i need to talk about two
things quickly before anything else
to read kemsley's dress um sickening
i don't have the words to describe what
that look
did for me from the dress to the fox to
the hair
she had little sparkles in her hair too
she's literally was the walking
embodiment of the true jacksonvp
theme song from her head to her toes
it's all real and you know
fresh and cool that's just what she does
what is spelling d o r i t
um i i was i had i still have no words
my
jaw hit the floor watching her walk
around all evening like i could
not get enough grace it was one of the
best elegance all of her looks
always are top-notch even her little
flip breathing vampire
[ __ ] loved it this was ash on another
level
astronomical insane like never been done
before never to be repeated put in a
blanket throw it up
give birth to it put it in a blender i i
if nothing else happened that episode
like
just being in her presence was
gratifying before we go to bed every
night we have to get on arnie's and pray
for
pk's business because whatever their
lifestyle is it must be maintained and
we've been led to believe
that it might not all be so you know
happy and good and lovey and they might
be having some financial problems and i
can't handle that because i need to read
to keep serving this level of
luke no i completely agree i i agree we
need to
pray that that it's all kosher over
there and i'm not going to see them on
an episode of american greed and her in
that newsboy cap
exactly okay second thing i need to talk
about kris jenner
kris jenner being so philanthropic chris
jenner being so
philanthropic seeing kris jenner on a
reality show that
isn't her own show it's like seeing a
dog walk on a time leg
it's that and it's also like seeing
a teacher out of school but also
there was something so elevated and like
when she walked into the room i'm like
oh my god kris jenner's at this party
but it's like no i know christina i
watch her on my tv all the time but like
seeing her through the eyes of the real
housewives of beverly hills
um like kris jenner is like
a superstar and she wasn't acting above
it she sat in the front with all the
ladies she didn't do
anything to make her seem like she was
above or
not down for any of it but just seeing
her on
this show and being like oh my god
that's chris jenner like her daughters
are the most famous women in the entire
world she has given birth to
not one but two billionaires like oh and
she gets temp
like i it was so weird for me to see her
through a different lens yeah no it was
she like
i almost didn't recognize her i i was
star struck
even though we see her on tv once a week
and she's always making a fool of
herself no i know
to see her like to see the way dorite
looks at her you know it was just
it was a new sensation it was fabulous
also a news an old sensation
was you know the ghost of housewives
past we had adrien malouf eileen
davidson
i [ __ ] love her she looked amazing
snatched i loved that brunette hair i
just i love everything about her and i
love the friendship
between her lisa and erica jane like
them in the car together is everything
brandi was there camille grandma was
there who allegedly came to like make
amends with everyone even though
it appeared as though she had no
interest in making amends with anyone
yeah you know what so she came like she
obviously had her tail between her legs
to a point
um she was she was willing to eat a
little a little bit of amber herds duty
but not the whole thing she was willing
to eat some [ __ ] i feel but when someone
comes up to you and says you're an
[ __ ] you know what she's still
camille grammar yes and she's not gonna
take that lightly and so i actually
appreciated
and i not necessarily appreciate it i
respected the fact
that she wasn't just gonna let these
girls pile on her
just to get on the show and negate
everything that she said last season
yeah and and
i don't even remember what went down and
i definitely wasn't on her side but
if you're gonna take a stance like she
did um
stick with it so i actually i i
appreciate her apologizing for the
things that she was sorry for
and not apologizing for the things that
she wasn't right um i do love seeing
brandon glanville back on the real
housewives of beverly hills and i
thought it was interesting
um why kyle like explained why she
invited her because last we left it they
like weren't on good terms
but kyle just said i think like brandi
is really misunderstood and they played
that video of her crying that she like
doesn't have a perfect husband and
perfect family with like
her kids 100 of the time and like she
struggles with that and i don't know i
always i will always have a soft spot in
my heart for brandon glenville because i
i've always felt that she was deeply
misunderstood
yeah i always loved her when she was on
the show the friendship between her and
lisa vanderpump like was the bragas was
similar to bethany and jill
um and i actually i took brandi side i
remember i read her books
yeah um i i used i loved her when she
was on the show i think
she would still be a great addition to
the cast especially now with the
the other element which is an alleged
affair with denise yeah and also the
reason why she went off the show pretty
much is because
of her fight with lisa and then she like
hit lisa in the face and lisa just would
never forgive her and
she couldn't get back into the group but
now that lisa's gone like i actually
think brandy is a quality housewife
and i love seeing her i and she's so
bubbly and fun and
and and she also is not afraid to to go
there and i do ship her and denise i'm
not gonna lie like when they give a hug
i'm like that is a beautiful couple
i know so it was great to see brendan
and i might i don't know if i
necessarily yet walk back what i said
about
kyle inviting all the women so she could
invite brandy no it seemed like it was
really like she pulled out all the stops
for this event yeah like she wanted the
most rich people in one room and i just
want to say the event
was spectacular sometimes with these
housewives events it's like clearly it's
just
a set for filming orange county fashion
week but this was a real soiree
and i loved what she said when she was
like i spent six figures on this event
and if i don't raise
200 000 then i'm gonna feel like i
should have just donated this money
which is how i feel about
these big functions all the time well
between
um kris jenner and garcelle she paid
five thousand dollars for that trip to
mexico they already made 30k so i feel
like the event was definitely a success
yes but she's saying she spent over a
hundred thousand dollars but then they
told us later that they
raised three hundred thousand so i
didn't see that so they netted positive
but um it was interesting just for i was
glad that she said that because i feel
like that's how a lot of
people feel about galas galas and
charity functions
i have three things i want to say one i
think the most important moment of the
episode was when they brought in that
real life auctioneer who
for true tv stands know that that is the
auctioneer from storage wars
okay dan and his wife i love sword
towards i think about storage wars all
the time you know he has gained a little
bit of weight so at first i didn't
recognize him but she said don watson
i'm like that is the guy i know it and i
googled it and it was him
wow second thing is garcelle's man was
just
everything of the sort and i love how
all the women were like truly like he
had this presence and like when jerry
went to give him a hug like
i think she fell in love a little bit
and i just love garcelle and i'm glad
that she finally showed up to a group
function
and the third thing i wanted to say was
the conversation between aaron and pk
was so funny like pk was just trying so
hard to get through to erin and aaron
wanted apps he was like yeah no i agree
yeah okay thanks bye darn is just so
stubborn it's really annoying because
other than that
like other than what's going on between
him and the women which is a lot it's
pretty much the whole storyline right
now but aside from that he seems like a
really
great husband partner and i like them
together and i like them together a lot
and so i just and i just feel like he
needs to look at pk and be like
if pk can come back if i'm saying like i
love
pk right now if he can come back from
where he was calling lisa schizophrenic
aaron is fine and
but he needs to be like open to
just backing down and hearing what
someone else has to say and just
apologizing and moving on
because it is becoming bigger and bigger
and bigger um also
i just there were so many positives
about the episode but i do have to
you know highlight one episode which was
lisa reyna's wig
in at the party yeah in her white tuxedo
i just it wasn't the look for me it
wasn't for you
no it was misshapen and it really looks
like a wig which it was but
interesting and you know the the beverly
hills
zoom um confessionals aren't terrible
no they're not i felt bad for camille
though because she finally like got back
on the show and then she had to do a
zoom confessional and
the just the acoustics in her house like
everything that she was saying kind of
sounded deranged
oh also this woman kimber that came with
okay
everyone knew her no you don't remember
her no she
any time camille has been in the scene
since season one like kimber
is right there next year when kyle went
to her house i thought at first i
thought kimber was yolanda
oh my god that was an iconic so excited
but it was not but no kimber is just
always with camille oh interesting i
literally she's so not memorable to me
but i was like how do all these women
know her
no she's been like go to season one
she's there also there was just so many
honestly iconic moments like the reunion
of adrian and paul nassif like that was
beautiful
it was really weird to see honestly and
when they did has a new thought
adrian has a new shot looks so different
she looks so different
and you know i'm all for plastic surgery
but at some point like you you do have
to stop and i think adrian will
reach that point like five years ago
yeah but i love
paul massif me too um and i'm so happy
for him and i think he was so
miserable in his marriage and on the on
the real housewives of beverly hills
that part of the reason why we love him
so much is because he has this whole new
like zest and appreciation for life
a whole new life he has a new he has a
new face too
he has a new job a new friend new
wife like everything it's all coming up
roses for paul nassif and i actually do
love to see it it's a real you know
american dream yeah paul massif yes um
kim richards was in attendance and he
looked adorable you know she's so sweet
like i
she too i she's not a great housewife
and not really a great television
character but i i do have a spot for her
a little corner for her in my heart
yes i agree she's lovely um and so on
the auction items looked spectacular i
think they were but you know
like it's hard to capture like the
essence of an auction on tv
yeah well but the party was sickening of
course kyle had her og
party planner glenn um and mauricio like
trying to figure out the pool i love
mauricio he's also one of my favorite
house husbands
yes and she's a great episode it was a
great episode
i love that kyle did invite so many of
the former cast mates because it was
really great to see them
and i hate when the episode breaks up in
the middle of an event like we have to
watch
next week that's really annoying um
but it was they brought out all the
stops for us i can't remember last time
we had like that level of glamour
elegance money rich everything yes
so i i really liked it so we say thank
you
you say thank you we say thank you to
dory um for that look for that look
kyle for the party and the fabulous
guest list yes and
kris jenner for her philanthropic work
and just being like the icon that she is
and showing up that was the philanthropy
was showing up to an episode of real
housewives
and then just you know donating out of
the goodness of her heart yeah that was
crazy
she just lifted her little stick 25 000.
fabulous i love her so much well that is
our tv recap and if there's not anything
else i think i'm gonna wrap this baby up
do it thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we
uh post videos on youtube monday through
friday we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radiocast box
our video our podcast episodes are
available on spotify and now our video
episodes are available there too
so that's fabulous if you want to listen
or watch on spotify you can and wherever
you listen to podcasts find us morning
toast and leave a five star review about
a beautiful stunning and smart we are we
hope you guys have an amazing day
and we will see you tomorrow goodbye
you